now note that once an object has been
created in the environment the physics
engine will simulate each frame updating
the position and velocity of any physics
bodies that it has in its world in order
for grits objects to properly receive
the data and update positions for the
rendering we need to query the physics
engine results via the physics bodies
created for an entity note that the
position values for an object already
exist as it's inherited from our entity
base class inside of our update loop
given that the entity has a physics body
we can query its position and update the
entity position accordingly this way the
visual representation of an object will
match the physical reputation as is to
do this you need to call the physics
body's get position method and then
assign it to our local positional values